Hi there :D!
Howsit goin bros
I am a Rick and Morty fan
I have an IQ of at least a thousand(omg) decibell, decimal
for I am an Rick and Morty fan
you have to have VEERY high IQ to understand Rick and Morty( u told us Felix)
The HUmor is extremly subtle
and without a solid grasp on theoretical physics, eh uh most of the jokes will go over the typical viewers HEaad
As consequence people who dislike Rick and Morty
...truly ARE IDIOTS( Einstein watches Rick an Morty so should you)
Of course they wouldn't appreciate. For instance *slight inhale
Tthe humor in Rick's "existential" catchphrase
*eyes pop x3* WUBBA LUBBA DUB DUB
Life is meaningless (I agree but u don't care tho poods)
BRRRAA BA BRA LA DUBBA DUB DAAHB
BIBBITY BAh BA PA DAH
I'm pickle Rick *Ear rape on the B* Bitch
You see? ( I'm blind u heartless D':)
Rick and Morty is not just an adult cartoon
It says something deep about lahyf (life)
They say somefin deep about laif!!
About life!
they say something deep about this adult cartoon (what an @*s#o!es :o)
Pickle Rick: I don't give a f***********
(ohhh it was so short :(, hey, if you're here thanks for watching and see ya :D!) *Outro Music in Description